[Music]
i was curious as to how i would
recommend handling narcissistic gift
giving that could include gifts that are
passive-aggressive mean-spirited
competitive
that involve what's known as
love-bombing or simply come with strings
attached we hear about practicing grace
and gratitude with those who don't hear
us about less being more
but how should one respond to a gift
that's given clearly as a put down or a
power play
narcissistic gift giving
dk it seems to me that
narcissistic gift-giving
is
i don't know like it's like loving
violence in a way it's like these things
are oxymoronic right because the spirit
of a gift
is what to add value to someone else's
life i i really dislike the idea that
gift giving is a love language
because it presupposes
that there is love in a thing quite
often right
and well you know us it's love people
use things but sometimes things can be
useful and so i like to uncouple the
gift from the love and the way that i do
that is by saying gift giving is no more
a love language than pig latin is a
romance language
now let's be clear i'm not saying gift
giving is bad or wrong
i'm not saying pig latin is bad or wrong
in fact it was quite fun when we were
kids to try to figure out how to reverse
the words and yet
people will think that i'm making a
judgment there we're going to talk to
ruslan a little bit about judgments but
i would like to talk to you right now tk
about this concept of love bombing or
narcissistic gift giving that laura from
new zealand brings up
yeah i was just watching this movie too
where there was a family party and there
are two sons and one of the sons was
engaged and he announced to his family
at the party that he is now engaged and
the parents were so proud and so happy
and there was the jealous brother who
was like oh you're not gonna one-up me
and so even though he's not even engaged
or interested in getting engaged he
grabs his girlfriend and goes up there
and sings a song and does this big
elegant show and says and we too are
engaged and she's like what he's like
just go with it go with it and the
parents are even more proud right and so
this is a classic example of
using good news
as a way to compete with someone else as
a way to signal i'm better than you i'm
gonna buy you this gift because the last
gift you bought me was so cheap this is
gonna show you that i'm the one that's
more caring in this relationship or
maybe you buy my mom a five dollar gift
and i chuckle condescendingly
well momsy i got you the 500 gift don't
you love me more
you know gift giving as competition
gift-giving as
self-congratulation the way you opt out
of that game is the same way you deal
with the game of tug-of-war that you
don't want to be a part of in order to
play tug-of-war
one person has to hold the rope on that
end the other person's got to hold the
rope on this end and as long as we're
both pulling man we got a game that's
capable of lasting forever and it will
be a test of strength because the one
that pulls the strongest will be able to
stand self-righteously above the other
and say i beat you but you can always
let your end of the rope go and the game
is instantly over and that person
doesn't look stronger in fact they kind
of look like a cloud as they fall
backwards in this vain game and when it
comes to narcissistic gift giving
you can simply opt out
you can just quit playing if someone's
giving you a passive aggressive gift you
can let them know i don't want it
i don't want it i don't like the spirit
that is behind it and i say no to that
if it's truly the thought that counts
well then never accept the gift with the
thought behind it that says fu
[Music]
yes
we often think that we can't opt out i
must play this game
and that becomes a trap because now i
feel as though
i have to do something i don't want to
do i'm obligated to give you a gift or
i'm obligated to accept your gift i'm
obligated to play the game that you're
playing or even worse i too am obligated
to be the narcissist to match your
energy
and
that destroys a relationship but when
you opt out
you're doing so lovingly you're not
saying screw you i hate you
i dislike you your gifts are whatever it
is it's simply saying hey
i'm not playing that game laura i'd love
to send you a copy of our book essential
there are 12 chapters in there 12 areas
of intentional living it's an essay
collection 150 different essays from the
minimalists and in that book there's an
entire chapter about minimalist gift
giving several essays about gifting but
with intention i think you'll enjoy that
if you enjoy our podcast we'll send you
the audiobook version of essential or if
you want the book book or the ebook
version we'll send those to you as well
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]